[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
can't figure out how to get her 25 year
old son to move out i have some ideas we
talked to a husband who's struggling in
his marriage after an affair we talked
to a dad whose 11 year old son is
struggling pornography stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up everybody this is john with
the dr john dolone's show
man we are solving problems
[Music]
taking care of your mental health your
physical health not your physical health
actually um
i'm in the middle of a book writing
deadline and man yesterday i pretty much
uh
eight bags of licorice
i did take some breaks for some chips
and salsa that's how i got my vegetables
rough couple of days so
oh not feeling super great
no i feel awesome actually i don't look
super great but i feel incredible
um but we are not talking about your
physical health but we're talking about
your mental health your relationships
talking about everything on the show and
sarah can i just say you have the single
greatest instagram of all of america
it's the most lovely and kind every time
it just flashes up on my internets
it's so great
and you're super talented you just hide
back there so good sarah edits the show
and
it what makes it look like we just
started talking um
she takes all of my is and stupids and
dumbs and all the words that we don't
see on internets and she takes them all
out and makes it look like i'm a
coherent thinker and speaker at the same
time
and if you just thought but you're not a
coherent thinker and speaker you should
see this show before sarah gets a hold
of it so that's awesome all right hey we
got a couple of poems
that people sent in
my favorite thing about america
is that some of you still use um
uh
pins and paper and stamps
god bless you
all right here is an ode to dr d
here we go i don't know who this is from
i'm just gonna say it's from america
in a time that is weird and not very
neat ramsay added a friend whose name
rhymes with meat
i see what you did there
he's honest he's funny and awkward for
real but share your emotions and he'll
help you deal
he uses wrong words and irritates kelly
agreed
calvary and cavalry make me laugh in my
belly
oh
mr doloney the king of horse noises
horse sounds
you're changing the world with advice
that abounds well i'll keep this brief
that's already pretty long i have stuff
to do
know that you're awesome we love you too
it's from kalina kalina
it makes my heart feel good kalina thank
you and one more poem somebody sent this
in a
in a card this is a fancy card like a
like a
like a
watercolor card
hannah d from lafayette minnesota i
thought lafayette was in louisiana but
everyone needs another lafayette right
i hate video games i really really do
i've got three under three in my home
crew
you're probably drinking brew we love to
go outside and take the dog on walks and
we have quite the collection of inside
special rocks
what does that mean
is that a drug reference or something i
think so
and on the show if for the um the
outtakes we will teach you how to cook
math we're working on making memories as
a family together to give them a
childhood my kids happily remember
a happy childhood often doesn't include
special rocks but i'm gonna give it to
you thank you hannah d this is lovely
and wonderful hey and kelly
you sent an email last night we have
listeners in russia
yes we do
her name was um olga olga was rocking it
she had some great inside jokes about
dave which cracked me up she's just
dropping some bombs one day which is so
good dude we are worldwide we are we're
big in russia and what most americans i
mean most americans what most listeners
don't know is my mom was recently in
russia and i think she logged in and
just sent that but i'll take it it's all
good she wasn't in russia but that's
just the story i'm telling myself all
right let's go to the p-h-o-n-e-s let's
talk to kathy in
boston
hey kathy listen
before we get going here okay i'm an
astros fan and if you're from boston
they're about to play your red sox by
the time this episode comes out we'll
know the outcome of this series but i'm
just letting you know just letting you
know okay i'm starting this conversation
a little bit on edge but that's cool so
what's up
well um thank you for taking my call you
got it and
um i have a situation at home um my
husband and i are both 52
and my son is 25
he lives at home he's been unemployed
for a year he doesn't collect
unemployment
and every time we try to get him out of
the house he refuses to leave
and he doesn't want to talk about
his past situation with his last job
which i do know what had happened
but he's using that as an excuse to why
he can't get a job that he needs to work
things through why do you
what do you mean he won't leave your
house what does that mean
well we've tried to kick him out a
couple times because he really um kicked
off me and my husband how do you try to
kick him out
like he's 25 year old man you tell him
you put all the stuff in the yard you
call the police
well he doesn't leave the house so it's
hard to
get into his room
and throw everything out kathy this is
your house
i i know he's your son i know you love
him
but it sounds like you're encouraging
him to leave or you might get loud but i
i feel like i'm enabling him yeah
absolutely one thousand percent
why doesn't he why doesn't he work what
happened at the last job
um
it's a long situation but basically just
in one sentence what happened
he misread a girl's
actions and he got fired for sexual
harassment but he did not you know he
nothing physical happened okay he got
fired for sexual harassment and what
does he do what's his trade what does he
do for a living what does he want to do
usually he works in warehouses but his
dream is to be a writer a director
and he stays at home and he
writes i mean he's not just playing
video games i mean he doesn't really
play video games but he's always in his
room whenever i go in there he's either
writing
reading
you know
not just
playing video games so here's the thing
he wants you know why he stays at home
because it's comfortable because he can
you know he doesn't have a job because
he can
why he
reads books as a 25 year old and isn't
contributing to your home or to his
community or even furthering his career
because he can
and my guess is
there's no
not my guess is there's no way this is
new
how long have you guys been propping him
up for probably since he was really
little huh
um
yeah but he's always been pretty
independent on us
on his own my daughter was the one who
needed all the attention but i mean he's
always
you know he's always been quiet
i mean
it's just this past year has been
it's just been he won't work he won't
get a job my husband and i have tried to
get him a job
between where i between my two jobs
he doesn't need one he doesn't need a
job
why would he work because it would be
insane for him to work
he has the greatest situation any 25
year old not with a romantic partner
could dream of
free food free rent he just gets to read
books all day and write the great
american novel or write a screenplay
he doesn't have to do anything
true
like like finding him a job is is like a
fruitless exercise
he's already he doesn't need one he's
got everything taken care of
and so what do you suggest oh go ahead
yeah i mean i don't you know what to do
i don't need to suggest anything to you
you have one of two options
you can continue just to support him and
then maybe one day
um
his great american screenplay will come
through
probably
less than
one one thousandth of a percent chance
that happens because screenwriters are
on set screenwriters are getting coffee
for people i know i've known
screenwriters
people in the industry are in the
industry they are hustling 365 24 7 and
then they write at night
they are around
films being made they are around other
writers they have writer's groups they
are sending their stuff they're always
in the middle of things
you want to you want to find people who
are in the film industry i work with
some of them they are all over the place
sarah right here makes movies in the
evening and edits them and cuts the i
mean it's a
people who are in that and make it are
doing it 24 7 365 they're not in their
mom's house
in
the reading books
so
he's not going to be successful doing
this but maybe maybe he'll send the
email that the great agent opens and
such and such
or you can give him the greatest gift a
parent could give him
which is responsibility
participation and consequences
accountability that's love
right that's what we want to give them
you don't want to make them homeless you
don't want to give it to him you want to
want to give it to him
no i do want to give it to him i'm just
afraid of making him homeless he might
be homeless but that won't be you making
him that would be a 25 year old man
choosing it
do you see the difference
i do
it's it it is not your responsibility if
you're a 25 year old man of a son
chooses to be homeless at this point
does he have mental health issues
does he have physical health issues
no physical health issues but um
you know mental illness goes on in the
family i mean i have my
um bipolar and um anxiety issues my
daughter has care issues i mean
do i think he's dealing with depression
yeah absolutely yeah millions of people
are dealing with depression it's been an
ugly ugly couple of years no question
about it
but my guess is
at some point a 24 year old is sitting
there staring at a warehouse and doesn't
know what to do next and then he just
cashes out here's what i'm gonna do i
want you to stay on the line i'm gonna
send you something for free for him
i'm gonna send you my friend ken coleman
has a career assessment he's got a new
book coming out i'm gonna send both of
them to you for free
okay oh thank you
but here's the thing
you're going to give that to him and
then you're going to give him well i'm
not going to tell you what to do because
here's what's going to happen i'm going
to tell you you need to kick him out
which you do
and then you're going to and then he's
going to be homeless and something's
going to happen you're going to blame me
that's what enablers do no no no okay so
i wouldn't blame you
if it's my kid he's out of my house in
30 days
he's out of my house in 60 days i might
even pay his first month's rent of his
new one-bedroom apartment
but he's got 60 days
30 days and then he's gone
and here's a couple of tools to help you
find out what you want to do because you
don't do warehouse forever maybe you do
maybe you want to work up the supply
chain
you're going to have to write your
screenplay at night cause you gotta eat
brother cause i'm not feeding you
anymore
i'm not paying your bills anymore
and kathy you know this you know this
right i do i really do and your husband
he knows this
absolutely so who's who's protecting
your son one of you two is is at the
last minute goes no no no let's let him
stay another night who is it is it you
me
me
man
love your son enough to hold him
responsible for his actions he's a 25
year old man now at the time
okay
so i guess uh
three days i'll be throwing his stuff
out the window
hey i've seen it where it gets ugly he
says i'm not leaving and then he's gonna
call your bluff
and then you gotta decide yeah that's
what he has been doing am i gonna call
the police
are we gonna take all of his stuff and
have it moved out of my of your home
and actually it's your stuff unless he
purchased it with his own money so if
it's beds and dressers and things that
y'all bought at y'alls
but at some point he's gonna call your
bluff and you're gonna have to decide
ahead of time so take your your husband
out and you say i'm sorry that i've been
kicking this candy on the road for five
10
15
20 years it's time for our son to grow
up
and i know it's hard and i know there's
a pandemic and blah blah blah he's got
to start grinding
he's got to start figuring out life as
our friend my friend henry cloud says
um what he's in desperate need is some
problems
he needs some actual problems like
hunger and
shelter
to get his butt in gear he's got to go
to work
and if you are 25 at home
working on your screenplay and you don't
have a job go get a job
figure it out
man it's frustrating
frustrating frustrating frustrating
and i know it's hard kathy now's the
time you got to make your move make your
move we'll be right back on the dr john
dolone show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i got to
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.com jaloni
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we're back jack
let's go to
not jack we're going to paul in denver
what's up paul how are we doing
good how are you man we are we are
rocking on to the break of dawn brother
all right huh
so what's up man
so let's kind of get straight straight
to it um so my wife and i have been
married for about 12 years
after the first year and a half
she had an affair
we ended up getting a divorce
within about three months of finding out
but then
we were young ended up working things
out went through counseling i got
remarried
fast forward a few few years later
while i was at work she packed up the
packed up the kids went to a family
member's house
he was only gone for a couple weeks
got back into counseling started working
on our marriage ourselves
worked things out
and then about two years ago
i found out that while she was gone
um
for those couple of weeks
she had
been going on a couple of dates with a
guy that she had worked with
or was was working with at the time
um
and that's
i found out about that two years ago um
but that all took place about five years
before i found out
um
you have a thread of mistrust your
relationship's built on a lack of trust
huh
yeah 100
you know and then there's there's been
financial
trust issues
yeah
right before i found out about this
i found out that she had credit cards
that i didn't know about she had
borrowed money from family members to
pay their credit cards so i didn't find
out about it
it's just it's kind of been
one thing after another
so
i guess my question is
uh i feel like i've i've forgiven her
um for a lot of it i feel like i've said
a lot of it down
um i still think about it obviously sure
but in return
uh over the last couple of years i have
felt
more emotionally and physically
disconnected from her sure um
she lies to you and cheats on you man
your feelings are valid brother
yeah like
yeah you're yeah you're right where you
need to be man this is a hard situation
yeah
um so i guess i'm just trying to figure
out how to move forward because
you know i i we've got two kids that's
kind of watching us we don't fight we
don't argue um
you know we say we love each other we
hug we kiss we you know we i guess put
on a front if you will
and
just trying to figure out how
how can i either get my marriage back on
track or when
when do you call it enough man
brother paul thanks for calling man
this is a hard phone call for you isn't
it
uh yeah more than you know yeah
because i'm i'm one of those kind of
macho guys i don't talk about stuff but
that's
right like you're you're a brave guy i
appreciate you calling dude
um i know i can tell in your voice you
don't have this conversation very often
with very many people and so uh it's an
honor and i'm grateful for the call man
and for what it's worth you're gonna
help a whole whole bunch of people
who are in the exact same situation
you're in so
um bravery's got a ripple effects that
can change hearts and and legacies of
people you'll never meet brothers so
thank you so much
um
so let's back up high five to you for
using the word set it down
for deciding i'm gonna forgive her i'm
not gonna poison myself
because she made some bad decisions and
you've recognized hey man i was young
and mature i'm sure you contributed to
mess inside your home she's done some
had some major integrity issues and some
violations i'm sure there was some give
and take all through this thing is that
fair over the last 12 years oh
absolutely all right absolutely so um
one of the things that's hard when
somebody cheats on you or somebody is
dishonest with you is you got to look in
the mirror and say did i create an
environment where somebody could be safe
doesn't excuse what they did but it's
good to look in the mirror and be
reflective and say what did i contribute
to this thing
did i set up a world where she had to go
hide money because i blew up or i
hoarded all the money or fill in the
blank right so let's fast forward to now
you've been to counseling a few times
you got divorced you gave another shot
you got remarried
and now you find yourself in a situation
where you're being the one that's not
honest
where you are playing
husband you're playing
love
and man you are two inches apart but 2
000 miles away from that woman is that
right
yeah yeah
so something about you thinks you are
worthy of a woman who cheats on you and
worthy of a woman who lies
and puts your financial health at risk
and
is setting a pretty dismal example for
your kids what is it about you brother
that makes you think how's this kind of
the way this is
honestly i don't know um i think i've
kind of just held on to everything that
uh
everything that we've been through i
guess in the past and the fact that i
know
uh you know i contributed to a lot of
the
um
not necessarily cheat because that's one
thing that i i've never
never been i mean i don't i don't agree
with it but
i contributed a lot to pushing her away
i guess throughout the years whether it
was
working uh drinking going out with
friends
maybe talking down to her at some point
i'm sure
so
i kind of hold on to that to say maybe
it's my fault i guess which is
kind of sounds stupid in in a way
no i mean it's not stupid brother you're
i mean you're taking ownership you're
being reflective that's what being a
wise adult who's wants to heal his life
you know what i mean so
i mean that's not stupid at all
it doesn't give somebody license to
continually abuse you
and
it doesn't give license for somebody to
lie and put your your physical health at
risk to put your financial health at
risk and put your children's health at
risk
um
because you've messed up too we all have
we've all said things we wish we could
take back and we've all fill in the
blank
the real the real question that we come
to right now is this what do you want to
do
you feel stuck and i want to take the
walls off you can snap your fingers what
would you do
be done
yeah i mean like yeah
say it out loud
say it out loud
i think i would be done um if
if what you know
i start thinking about my kids and my
kids future and and i got that i got
that here's the thing your kids are
absorbing that disconnection they're
absorbing the fake relationship
and they can't put their finger on it
but they know
and my guess is you grew up in a house
like that too
yeah you'd be right
and so your your kids are going to
absorb it and that's what they're going
to know they're not going to know two
people who are madly in love with each
other and who have disagreements and who
come back to the table and come back to
the table and
who are connected in their own weird
ways they're gonna know performance
they're gonna know hug at the right
moment and
pursed lips pet kiss at the right moment
and then dad goes upstairs or down in
the basement and grabs a beer
and then mom gets on her phone
that's what their picture of marriage
and love is going to look like
and if y'all are willing to both get in
and root that out awesome
but you don't trust this woman and she
hasn't been trustworthy and my guess is
she doesn't trust you either
and that is a recipe for ash
it's fair
does she trust worthy now has she
changed
uh yeah i mean i would say she's a
completely different person
just the way she carries herself
the way that she acts how involved she
is
you know you've given me a bunch of
performance attributes can you trust her
yeah i mean i think that height does she
love being honest with you
yeah
okay sorry i cut you off man be honest
with me
um
yeah i do trust her i i do um
but there's there's a there's that doubt
right yeah because i trusted her before
and i was always that person that said
that uh
um
she was one of the most honest people
i've ever met in my life and she was in
my face yeah well and here's where it
blows up in your face man
because you don't trust you now
yeah you don't trust her but you don't
trust yourself either you don't trust
yourself to not snap you don't trust
yourself to not hide to not stay out too
late not to have one too many drinks you
don't trust yourself
to
pick the right girl
and until paul starts trusting paul
again paul's not going to trust anybody
are you a good dad
yeah
have you changed too as a husband
yeah
so why don't you forgive paul
i don't know
you haven't forgiven you yet man
are you worthy
how do you do that
you write yourself a letter dear paul
i'm sorry
i'm sorry that i wasn't the husband that
i wanted to be i'm sorry that
contributed to mess in this home i'm
sorry that i don't trust myself anymore
i'm not sorry that i gave my wife a
second and third and fourth chance and
i'm not sorry that i'm trying to be a
great dad
but i'm sorry that i lost trust in you
and that ends today
and then over the next two months three
months six months when those moments of
self-doubt
creep in you have somebody that you're
gonna call or somebody you're gonna text
or you stand up and say nope paul you're
a good dad and you're a good husband
and what happens is you practice that
kind of language to yourself you stop
talking to paul
in ways that you would never let
somebody else talk to your neighbor
but you forgive
paul when you forgive paul you could
continue to forgive your wife or
you can set that brick down that you're
not good you're not good enough this is
what you deserve and you can demand
better
when's the last time you just fell
asleep at night
and slept hard without any
sleep anything without a couple of beers
you just went to sleep
it's been a while when's the last time
you and your wife got to laughing so
hard your guts hurt and then y'all ended
up making out and it was awesome
i couldn't tell you that exactly
listen to me very carefully
your life is worth that
you paul are worth that that's called
joy it's called peace
is the last time somebody cut you off in
traffic and you just started laughing
instead of gripping the wheel so tight
the last time a politician said
something stupid and you rolled your
eyes instead of your heart rate going up
that's peace brother
and you deserve that
here's here's what here's just this guy
to guy here's let me tell you
you're not crazy for not wanting to put
your hand back in the bag when you know
there's a rattlesnake in there you've
been bit a few times that's okay you're
not a bad husband you're not a bad guy
you're not crazy you've been cheated on
you've been you've experienced financial
infidelity you've been cheated on
several times quite a few times actually
you're not crazy for having that little
voice in the back your head
your wife has to understand that
that's part of healing
you also
have to ask for forgiveness and you got
to forgive yourself if you haven't
already that's the next step for you
brother is you're going to sit down your
wife and say i'm going to ask you to
forgive me
and all you can control is you your
thoughts and your behaviors and so from
this point forward from today on you can
start talking to paul as though he's a
man of character man of integrity and a
dad doing the best he can
and a husband doing the best he can do i
have your word on that brother
absolutely you'll start treating paul
with respect
yep okay
and then here's the only way forward man
is you and your wife go somewhere and
you sit down and you look each other in
the eye and you you lay it all on the
table
i'm struggling we are not connected
we're playing house
and i want to dream about what this
marriage could look like
and then we're gonna we're gonna pick
the town and the home and we're gonna
backfill it
reverse engineer it here's what it would
look like
every day to wake up and say i love you
we're gonna hold hands for five minutes
30 seconds
i will put a note on the mirror in our
bathroom every single day seven days a
week for the next six months next two
months
i will ask you what i can do to help you
out today and she will ask you what she
can ask you i mean what she can do to
help you
we're gonna get that granular and we're
going to decide to begin to practice
desire we're going to decide to practice
dating each other again we're going to
decide
that when negative thoughts come up i'm
going to be open about them i'm going to
be honest about them and if you have
those moments where you think oh man i
didn't remember her having that purse
and then boom the alarms go off that
she's borrowing money or taking money
again
you get to ask hey are we still in the
up and up financially and she's going to
say yeah baby i'm with
you when she's out too late or she's
checking her phone a lot and kind of
hiding it you get to ask
hey are we still connected one-on-one
you're still with me right she can say
yep i'm still with you
you're gonna practice this thing step by
step by step and along the way you're
gonna teach your kids what marriage and
love and connection and forgiveness
and gritty reality of it looks like and
you can look up two years five years ten
years and you're gonna be a
ninja couple
or you're gonna get four months in and
say hey i'm not i'm out
but you can't do marriage halfway
you gotta be all in or you gotta be out
what are you what are you going to be
man
you ain't going to hurt my feelings
either way i'm going home to my wife my
on my own
you all in are all out
i'm gonna go all in
um
and i feel like i i feel like i'm saying
i'm going all in but i still got the
reality that i'm not going to be all in
or feel like i'm not going to be all in
um
and i don't know a lot it is
paul going all in doesn't mean
your radars are not still up going all
in doesn't mean you're naive and idiotic
going all in says i'm going to be honest
intentional and direct and we're going
to practice this thing until the ship
turns around
that's what that means going all in says
i'm gonna stop beating myself up all the
time all the time all the time
i'm gonna forgive paul
if i have to say sorry to my kids i'm
gonna say sorry to my kids
if i got other people in my life i gotta
say sorry too i'm gonna say sorry to him
i'm gonna write myself a letter i'll do
it every day
you're gonna do something really tough
really hardcore paul get a journal and
write to yourself
it's easy to lift weights and to talk
crap at a bar it's really hard to be
honest with yourself
that's brave that's strength that's hard
do that
[Music]
make the commitment either in or out
an end doesn't mean you're going to
stumble you won't fall down you won't
screw up you won't have bad thoughts in
just means i'm in
[Music]
have that conversation take your wife
out to breakfast so you all go to have
this hard conversation
something tells me she's wrestling with
this too
she's either halfway out the door or she
misses you
like the sun and the moon and the stars
my brother
somebody's got to turn their lights on
and make a call
your move brother we'll be right back on
the dr john dolani show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back
why
why do i do that with my voice
i want to be in a metal band so bad
but i ended up on a relationship podcast
my 18 year old self would be so
unimpressed
we thought i'd have like a mohawk and
lots of tattoos
i got a lot of tattoos but they're
covered in my shirts i want them like
sleeves i was going to be so cool
everybody
and i got a parenting podcast so here we
go all right let's go to william in
dayton ohio with my regular voice what's
up brother how are we how we doing
doing good john how about yourself we
were we were partying in here man that's
not really true we're not we're just
hanging out drinking tea so what's up
man
well
a little background real quick i have
two children that come into my home
seven years ago uh they're my great
niece and nephew
and the nephew is now on well he just
turned 12 and we're having some
disciplinary issues with him and now
he's starting even to dabble into
pornography
so how did he end up in your house man
well his parents were heroin addicts and
one night we got a call
that they were going to be taken by
children's services so we said we're in
we'll take these kids what a study i
know
we're parents again you know i mean we
were just about to be paroled from our
kids
and
here we are again you know but it's like
you're empty nesters and then birds from
above just fell back into your nest and
you're like oh here we go hey high five
do you man
for not by your hand but in your lap
something a problem a challenge drops
itself in your front yard and you and
you married
yeah yeah me and my wife been married
now 17 years man you all stepped up and
said come on in and good for you guys
that's incredible where are is it your
brother or your brother-in-law your
sister
it's my nephew's children
okay so yeah where are where are they
how are they doing
okay the mother we have no idea where
she is at this time um but the father he
is recovering from heroin he's been
clean for a year wow and we have slowly
been introducing him back into their
lives but it's been extremely careful
okay
good for them man
that's and
he's totally respected us as far as
parents go he doesn't try to jump up and
say hey i'm their dad i can say this and
i can do no whatever we say goes and he
respects us for that that's nice that's
incred that's incredible that means
you're drawing great boundaries that
means even through his healing and
recovery he knows y'all were there for
him and for his kids that's a family
that speaks truth to each other what i
mean you're a model for for for folks
around so good for you brother so we've
worked hard at it well it's hard it is
hard man it's hard work you got to
practice it it's tough so you have a now
uh 12 year old little boy and then your
daughter how old is she
she is eight
okay
so
12 year old
is into into pornography what you say
there's some uh
there's some disciplinary issues what's
been going on
well i mean i tell you that the boy will
lie to you when the truth sounds better
you know yeah just he you can't trust
what he says and we i mean we're almost
like helicopter parents to the extreme
because now when he says something
it's your homework now we have to go
back check everything make sure it's all
done because then he's going to fall
behind because it's not done yeah you
know and we we've even my wife even put
together like a clipboard list of them
things to do in the evening and in the
morning so they can stay on task with
their responsibilities
and you can say hey did you do your
clipboard yep we did it no they didn't
you got it you got to basically follow
it around and make sure it all gets done
and i mean we're seven years in and my
wife and i we're we're very
we're very proactive parents you know we
don't we're not the kind of parent that
threatens and then doesn't follow
through we absolutely believe that a
consequence has to come with a decision
that they make good or bad you know
there's there's something going to
happen
and you know if we feel like if we don't
follow through then we become liars to
the children and we're not going to do
that we're going to follow through they
know what's going to happen right
and you know we're that's just the way
we've always parented but like like i
said right now and and
the boy
he's extremely intelligent he really is
i mean he's he's with the honor roll
last year
but this year he's decided to shut his
responsibilities
and you know we're not big video game
people and stuff we don't we don't allow
the kids to have free they don't have
cell phones they don't have ipads and
stuff and if they do use ours it's under
very strict supervision sure but you
know he would get up in the middle of
last film about a week ago about two
weeks ago he got up in the middle of the
night
he won the ipad and we found him in his
bedroom at 3am looking at porn
and i'm like you know and i understand
puberty i get all that but he and i've
tried to explain to him the dangers of
what he's messing with and we're about
to have the internet just removed from
our house we don't need it you know i
mean it's just it's too dangerous it's
like having a loaded gun in the house
there you go man
so
number one you nailed it
like i i don't begrudge a 12 year old
for wanting to see
naked people having sex
right he's 12 right so i i want to take
off he's not dysfunctional he's not
screwed up he's absolutely plugged in
normal i don't i don't it does that
doesn't get my heart rate up
um even figuring out a way at 3am to
find it you know if if back when you
were a kid if you knew your dad had a
playboy hidden somewhere in the house
you'd wait till 2 a.m and you'd try to
find it right so that that part you're
absolutely right that part doesn't get
my heart rate up
here's where you have the the the great
challenges it lies before you
a couple of them number one
these children their earliest memories
and when i say memories i don't mean
cognitive memories i mean memories that
have been encoded into their bodies
is one of addicts
heroin addicts opiate addicts who were
present but not present and probably no
one will ever fully understand what was
going on in those homes
in the homes they were in the homes that
their parents didn't show up and they
didn't come back home or they slept for
three days whatever that looked like
man we would probably never know what
those kids saw and or experienced
you're right what they do know is that
even when you're talking about a heroin
addict
it's very similar to alcoholic
your mom can be looking you in the eye
and be completely not present with you
or she can disappear in the house on the
couch for a day two days or three days
at a time
the word i'm getting at here that is
encoded into your child and you're into
the kids that you're raising is
disconnection
yeah and so
your son found some
pseudo connection through performance he
made the honor roll did all the stuff
he's also finding disconnection through
doing nothing
because you
still reach out to him you're still loud
you still hold him accountable and he's
seen
the only way through this road and it's
going to be hard you're talking neural
synapse
growth
it's going to take weeks and days and
months and years
is he has to understand that he is a
being of value and he's got a
participation role the house cannot
function without him and he's gonna have
to learn the weight of what connection
actually means
and for my my dad
i knew that he loved me
and when he gave me jobs and i didn't do
them
accountability and consequence look like
x your accountability and consequence is
going to have to look different
here's what i mean by that have you
heard me talk about why i'm calling yeah
that's awesome hey it's awesome and hey
i don't get a lot of dads who say i love
my kid this much that i'm willing to
i've been running you know i was running
the run and shoot offense and it's not
working so can
is it a possibility we can run the ball
right that's rare that a dad does that
especially a dad on
on round two you know everything and
you're still
being humble enough to say is there
another way here man so i i mean i'm
telling you you're a model for dads out
there good for you brother
well i thought i knew
i know i don't i learned a whole new
rule
so
here here's what i did in my house okay
i'm just gonna tell you what i did in my
house
um
and you may have heard me say this
before and i'll say it a thousand times
again
is i went to and it sounds cheesy and it
sounds lame you can do this however it
works in your house when i was when my
kids were young young we did it one way
we're about to redo it and it will be a
lot more funny and we'll be a lot more
silly and winking at each other we'll be
a little more sarcastic about it but the
goal in in the route is still the same
we went and got a canvas at like uh
michael's or one of those craft stores
crafts etc one of those kind of stores
and you can use a two by four i don't i
mean i'm not two by four but like
plywood i don't care how you do it
but we sat together and we created the
delony family values here's who we are
and the kids got to speak into it we
tell the truth we all have adventures we
say yes we treat each other with dignity
we set up from the floor up here's who
we are here's what it means to be a
deloney
and then what i realized i was doing is
we'd be about to go fishing me and my
son about to go fishing he would not
have done his chores or something and
then i'd say well we're not going
fishing
and what i
because you did this i'm not taking you
fishing
and what i did was i began to weaponize
my relationship with him
if you don't do what i want you don't
have access to me
what i ended up doing now is i flipped
it
the same consequence happens if he
hasn't done his things
he knows that the house relies on a part
of the house functions because he's in
this family
and if he doesn't get his chores done
his stuff done that we agreed on what
would have to happen before we go
fishing my language i point back to our
values and i tell him dude
man i'm choosing to be heartbroken today
because you opted out of going fishing
you didn't want to go with me
and you demonstrated that by
x and y and z
and what he learns in real quick fashion
i'm going to tell you it changed our
house
positively
as he grew to understand really quickly
that he has a he gets to choose his
behaviors he gets to choose his thoughts
and he gets to choose what happens next
not me i'm not weaponizing my
relationship i want to go
but he opted out
and when he's married this is going to
pay dividends when he's going to college
and he realizes oh i chose to get an f
because i chose not to study
i chose to get fired from this job
because i had chose not to
be on time i chose not to fill in the
blank
he's learning early on that he has a
role not
that other people are just going to be
lobbing grenades at him
so
often children lie
they lie because they don't believe they
can
measure up
because there's a performative value to
the relationship in their home
or because they just get exhausted they
don't deal with it
they don't like the two hour
conversations the
of or over the 20 questions the 40
questions the x and y's and these and so
what i want parents to do who've got
kids who are lying to him is really
simplify your message
you can't talk a 12 year old can't
comprehend all this stuff they're 12.
they can't do two-hour three-hour
marathon sessions they're 12.
what they can do very simply is hey as a
family we said we don't lie
i hate that you chose to lie man here's
x y and z here's what you chose
please consider choosing something else
tomorrow because we love you having you
around
in this house we treat each other with
dignity you're not going to swear at the
dinner table at somebody you're not
going to tell like my wife that you hate
her and that's coming by the way as he
figures out y'all aren't my parents
those are my parents i want to go home
all that kind of nonsense that's that's
coming down the down the pipe for you
man i hate that you opted out of being
with us
hate that because we love having you
here you're a valued member of this
table
and so do you see how subtle this is the
same thing still happened but you are
letting him know this house rests on him
too he is a not fully he can't handle
that kind of weight but slowly over time
he's 12 13 15 17. he has to understand
oh man i've got strength this guy loves
me he's not going to lecture me he's not
going to try to talk to me all the time
but man he he counts on me and he leans
on me and i've got a choice in how this
thing runs
right and here's where the the final dot
dot here here's where this gets really
hard for you
he can opt out
he can opt out
and he's got to own those consequences
he's got to own those choices but he
can't own him until you've trained him
on what owning looks like
once you train him on here's what
ownership looks like here's how this
works and remember you are regrowing
this young man's brain
because he's been through hell his
body's been through hell he's never been
connected to an adult he's done what
they say
he knows they're bigger than him and
more powerful than him and they provide
him food and a roof
but he's never been connected to one
yeah i agree
he uh
it's like he doesn't really
there's a trust issue there and i
understand why
you know and we just try to keep
building that bridge but he has such a
hard time of expressing he feels about
stuff
so he does not know how to put it into
words so here's what i want to give you
um
i've had people write into this show and
tell me that they thought this was the
stupidest advice and it's been magic in
their home with their teenager i want
you to try it
i want you to
get a journal overspend on it get
something nice
and it's going to be just a
communication log between the two of you
and i want you to write him a note make
a commitment to write him a note it
could be two sentences it could be a
paragraph
every day i want you to write in there
to him and you leave it on his bed and
his job is to write something back
it can be
don't want to talk
thank you
today was a good day
but i want you to write a couple of
things that you saw in him that day that
were great
even if it's putting the toothpaste cap
back on
right whatever that is but he can see it
in writing he can hold it it's tangible
and what an addict's kid does is they
slough off the good stuff and they are
hyper alert for the bad stuff where am i
disconnected where am i going to get
left again and when you write it down on
a piece of paper on on and he holds and
it's on his bed when he goes in his room
after school and he sees it
man
that's good stuff that guy's still there
and his the rule is you got it right
back he can't just read it and throw it
on the floor he's got right back and his
job is to find a special place in the
house we can put it your wife can set
one up with him too maybe she does one
with your daughter
and by the way be vulnerable tell him i
had a hard day today
work was tough it was really i i didn't
want to get out of bed today let him
know what it's like because he's looking
at you as though you're perfect and
you're a drill sergeant and you are
running the show let him know hey man
this is hard
i'm tired sometimes i don't think i'm a
very good dad
sometimes i want to be better for you
let him know those things and he's not
going to think he's crazy
if he will 30 second hugs every day
my son's almost 12 30 second hugs every
day i ask his permission i don't i don't
like grab him and say no
and he's like oh dude
but we do it and it's big time
you think how can we slowly build
connection doesn't mean you let him off
the hook doesn't mean that you don't
hold him accountable you got to do those
things doesn't mean you don't quote
unquote punish him
you got to do those things
but the punishment is letting him know
god you opted out
i hate that
hey that you made this choice
please consider making a different
choice tomorrow because i want to go
fishing man
i want to go fishing with you
this house needs you
please consider rejoining us man
and then that night in that journal
so grateful for you i love you so glad
that you live in my house and that we
get to spend this time together
so glad god brought me to you
evoke the cosmos brother
and then william be grateful graceful
with yourself
be graceful with yourself man this kid's
got a hard row and his head and his
heart are different than yours and mine
i don't know i say i don't know if you
grew up with addiction or not but
he's got to learn what connection looks
like
and man if you get to a place where
you've got to take the uh internet out
of the house so be it you could probably
just take the ipads and lock them up in
your room put them under your bed or
something like that if you take the
whole internet out but you're right the
internet's like having a loaded gun in
your house that's a great analogy man um
and good for you for being vigilant good
for you for being vigilant man
um don't beat your 11 or 12 year old up
for wanting to see naked people that's
normal
um your job is to stand in that gap and
take away as much access as possible and
by the way you can tell them
[Laughter]
to dad's everywhere you can tell your 12
year old you know what this is doing to
your mind and it sounds like the teacher
on charlie brown
naked people are awesome
and 12 year olds just not figuring that
out um
somebody just walked through the lobby
and i said that and they just looked at
me like ah this show got off the rails
um yes
job is to stand in the gap for your 12
year old access
it's your job to stand in the gap and
prohibit that man make sure they can't
get in get a hold of it i know it's
everywhere notes at school i know it's
on their friend's phones
not in my house
thank you so so much for the call
william all right as we wrap up today's
show
this song is submitted by dawn
uh-oh now we're getting dicey we're
taking caller submissions
oh dawn oh dawn here
dawn i love dawn she's so great
song is written by tony joe white we got
three names a three-namer
recorded by brook benton the song is
rainy night in georgia
and it goes like this hovering by my
suitcase trying to find a warm place to
spend the night
heavy rains falling seems i hear your
voice calling it's all right
a rainy night in georgia a rainy night
in georgia lord
i believe it's raining all over the
world this is the most georgia song i've
ever heard it referred to georgia eight
times and said lord
neon signs flashing taxi cabs and buses
passing through the night lord
i believe it's raining all over the
world thanks dawn this has been the dr
john dolone's show